[Music]
on an island off the coast of Scotland
something was summoned from the depths
of hell
something that would end mankind you sir
thing worried about today show up
you did
we face every breath there is and yet
you take me in
hello son made me a weapon where's my
fire there
mr. Loeb ladies in general out there
there's a fifth-century sorceress who
want to bring down the curtain on London
and the world
great homework
[Music]
why do you fight for those who hates and
fear you
you are meant for this
the ashes
okay I'd appreciate a prophecy with more
relatable steaks saving the world or
something yeah okay come on let's get
you in free stuff
yeah come on let's do this
[Music]
be my king
we belong together here in time
we do but this is not gonna work you
know cuz I'm a Capricorn and you're not
[Music]
do you recall the Osiris Club oh yeah
sit down Julie
now the other one the British are called
Society phone in 1866 by the ranking
members of the Helio pick brotherhood of
rah-rah a mera once in the underworld
use the glow Stalker
you know like us they fight against the
forces of darkness and our organizations
have a long-standing relationship there
are old friends of mine and they've
requested your assistance with a giant
problem
well more flop giants you think you're
going
to give back to a new world water
innocent people why do you fight for
this who hates of fear you all I wanted
was revenge until I saw you you can
usher in the apocalypse out of the ashes
a new Eden will emerge leave this frail
that's humans behind be my kid be
revered for who you really are
where are we trick-or-treating or
hunting Giants tradition one of the
brave Huntsman who come before from the
pig stickers
another tradition used by giants Slayers
throughout the ages with a he modern
modifications of course five times as
potent as an electric chair not enough
to kill a giant mind you but still quite
handy in subduing the creatures would
you care for one that's all right I got
positions a mile oh good
afterward I had to I you know we're very
well aware of your distaste for horns
it's my honor its master of the hunt to
wear the headdress mmm she's the queen
of blood and the [ __ ] good reason
all right
[Music]
we need L boy about goddamn time to
discover the hell with this
have you got to be saving the world or
something
good eat are my job is to protect the
world from Cookie Monster
he will need sections of your maids
bones of your enemies until [ __ ] done
if you're gonna make a helped one movie
you have to embrace the comic this
Hellboy is based in the comic The Wild
Hunt
it's so exciting when you hear
somebody's gonna make a movie close to
my material in this dome in particular
there are so many moments directly from
the comic the focus is one story but
bringing in enough elements that you get
a look at a big health away world the
fact that I get to be part of Hellboy
and I sort of got to pinch myself I
can't believe it he's unlike any other
superhero I knew the comments very well
and I love this real dark foreboding our
world with these big cathedrals epic
king arthur tombs in this gothic world
of monsters oh yeah the comics still
many people read them since they were 10
years old I'm just so excited to make
something really fun everyone
illustrations are phenomenal had great
action and really interesting characters
I was so excited to see the Blood Queen
and grew GOC monster and this incredible
giant fight
we've had a lot of fun going back to
this great comic well that Mike Mignola
created we wanted to push into a deeper
darker place I think it would be a very
impressive spectacle somebody was
summoned from the depths of hell
something that would end mankind when
the Sur thing didn't show up oh yes you
did
we fight against the forces of darkness
come on kids face off
Cal Poly these are our April 12
financing this cookie straight
we did a lot of practical stuff one
seven
we wanted to use makeup and costumes as
much as possible we're really lucky to
have the Academy Award winning makeup
artist Joel Harlow working on this movie
he's a genius
don't you look lovely we were going to
break new ground with prosthetics and
performance
who doesn't want to see a good
old-fashioned monster fight I like price
me
everything just has a more real effect
to it when it's practical I can see it
all
the work that's been done on this movie
it's sign boggling you have to see it to
believe it he warned us that something
was coming
if there is ever an end in this forever
war it will be because of you and your
strong right hand where the line in the
sand we fight against the forces of
darkness this is the expecting a sign
that says secret headquarters oh I need
some ID love um are you serious made me
a damn weapon I just wanted to help you
become the best you
[Applause]
some dads get their kids Legos you
saving the world or something
does it do anything special yeah it
smashes things real good
[Music]
you are mankind's best and only hope
especially fighting monsters not working
with
you calling monster pal you looking at
me recently
these are just inside
[Music]
[Music]
you